je voudrais proposer de faire un action
ou vérité c'est très simple j'ai plein
d'action ici alors je vais décrocher une
à une
bien entendu il ya des questions qui
sont arrivés si je ne veux pas répondre
à une question je vous le dis je pioche
serait bien entendu j'ai pas répondre à
une directive clocheret une action ici
d'accord alors question demain tu pars
sur une île déserte pour trois mois
tu dois choisir entre joey starr et
michel cymes qui choisis tu alors ben je
vais vous dire c'est simple franchement
je choisis joey starr ouais voilà voilà
je peux répondre à cette question je
choisis joey starr voilà parce que bon
c'est ses limites doucement délire quoi
michel cymes non merci s'est montré peu
pour moi la nasa la vérité cyril quelle
est la chose la plus folle que tu aies
jamais fait pour essayer de plaire à
quelqu'un voilà et il met une action
parler avec l'accent mars et jusqu'au
bout de l'émission alors ça je le savais
être cesser j'adore actions merci mais
je vais piocher une action ici quelle
est la chose la plus folle que tu aies
jamais fait pour quelqu'un pour faire à
quelqu'un et ben je vais vous dire je
vais prendre plutôt une nation donc j'en
ai pioché une action tout de suite une
action à faire un tu l'as vu à chantal
ladesou tu l'as vu vers un tu avais mon
cul à chantal ladesou donc je vais
l'appeler
je vais l'appeler directement de mon
portable chantal ladesou et je vais
essayer de lui faire un tu l'as vu
qu'ils mon cul allez c'est parti
c'est donc le premier défi voilà chantal
ladesou je laisse est parti on y va
chantal ladesou je l'appelle à les faire
à tulle avait à chantal ladesou alors
apparemment sa notation je vais vous
dire s il ya un mec qui répond pas en ce
moment c'est vraiment ils vous aiment
pas franchement on n'a rien d'autre à
faire que de répondre au téléphone ça
veut dire le mec qui te répond pas il te
déteste et tué apparemment c'est le cas
de chantal ladesou
par mois peut pas me plairait bizarre je
crois qu'ils aiment qui fait je suivais
ça message
chantal c'est hanouna rappelle moi je
t'embrasse bon chantal ladesou notamment
elle va me rappeler y'a pas de problème
notre question pour moi ça du match et
riz dans l'action vérité quel est ton
chroniqueurs préférés
ça je ne peux pas répondre de en plus
surtout en ce moment donc je prends une
action une action à faire dix pompes à
la crème sous une assiette de crem alors
ah ben voilà voilà lorsque on a
l'acceptera pas très bien mais il faut
que je me fasse assiette de crem alors
c'est très simple faire dix pompes
voilà donc la assiette de crem on y va
voilà vous pouvez le faire chez vous ça
ça marche très très fort regardez donc
là je préfère prendre cette action donc
voilà dix pompes sur a7 de crème si on
pouvait mener une serviette il ya
quelqu'un qui est là attention c'est
parti
attention c'est parti 2 3 4
ca c 'est mais les dés voilà on est bien
salut l'ami ça c'est fait ça c'était de
l'action on y va continuer à m'envoyer
aux actions ou aux vérités on continue
les chéris ça y est je ne vois plus rien
j'enlève les lunettes germé traite à
leurs échecs bon on a quoi lol quel est
ton chroniqueurs préférés ensuite peux
tu nous dire le long d'une prochaine
recrue dans tpm pays où as tu une
personne en tête que tu voudras à voir
dans la bande de chroniqueurs pour la
saison prochaine alors pour l'instant
franchement je crois que parce que je
sais pas je ne sais pas pour l'instant
j'aimerais garder l'équipe en place
parce que c'est vrai que déjà il me
manque
et si vraiment il ya quelqu'un que j'ai
très envie de voir
bah je le prendrai à mai
faire une florent panure c'est-à-dire
tremper sa tête dans la peinture et
chanter du flore open soir où on va être
obligé de le faire
chanter pour oublier ses peines
au bar sert un enfant chanter pour
pouvoir lire je t'aime je t'aime et
chanter tout le temps tout le temps pour
un 'plus' l ensemble en une seule et
même église soit retrouvé l'essentiel de
faire que les promenades
voilà merci bon ça fait je vais pas
faire toutes les actions cotent pas
merci merci
les cherry on agira d une mallié au
téléphone les chéris géraldine manier
salut ma chérie ça lui jugé un contenu
par le téléphone comment ça va ma chérie
tu tapes été verrouillées ou pas qu'est
ce qu'elle a ma chérie tu peux appeler
barbouillé ou pas non pas du tout non
pas du tout mais bien entre garde fou
noir avec david furnish est là pour vous
détendre on fait des combats là on était
en cours de combat qu'emploie avec
plaisir tu vas battre c'est que tu me tu
sais que tu me manques
ah ben tu sais que tu me manques moi
j'suis république type le mans comment
les mots je te fais un oeil les gossip
girl est très très fort on les embrasse
tous d'ailleurs j'ai eu des nouvelles de
soria aussi je t'embrasse fort ma chérie
on t'aime fort ça du monde il ya une
question pour es tu passé un appel à
notre salut ma chérie pourrais-tu passer
un appel à notre camille combal s'il te
plaît baba alors ça je fais la vérité
bajeux je vais essayer de le faire tout
de suite je vais essayer d'appeler
camille combal
on va voir s'ils me répond c'est parti
je vous rappelle que si les personnes ne
nous répondent pas en ce moment c'est
que vraiment elle ne nous aiment pas
parce que là tout le monde répond
chantal ladesou à mon avis elle doit
faire dodo la peau on après tout de
suite camille combal
c'est parti bon bah voilà ça c'est fait
ça c'est fait donc on va voir s'ils me
rappelle et en plus je peux pas prendre
de messages voilà les cherry on continue
les questions à wisches hamon voit des
questions tient vérité qu'elle est
l'invité que tu as pu recevoir dans
toute ta carrière et qui a été le pire à
gérer voilà alors le pire invités de
toute ma carrière va se passer l'autre
c'est comme ils s'appellent à
l'américaine la highway attendez
attendez que charlize theron voilà c'est
ça charlize theron lala charlize theron
states and in rue tu pouvais rien faire
et je vous jure j'ai un grand regret
c'est de ne pas l'avoir chocolatées ça
j'aurais chocolatées on aurait fait une
dar k dans le monde entier dans des
comptes les images reprises dans le
monde entier ont raconté ce qui s'est
passé sur charlize theron c'est qu'après
des missions jésuites
venir celle-là on m'a dit non mais
c'était obligé parce que en fait voilà
il voulait venir chez nous pour la
promotion du film de films en plus il ya
une énorme banane et avant l'émission
déjà je la croise dans les couloirs
peut-être comme ça une pastèque comme
pas possible elle macaci lennox bon
derrière j'ai beau plateau que tata va
se détendre à va être sympathique la
charlize theron
elle arrive déjà à la limite heures au
maquillage parce que charlize theron
c'est une star ont donc eu huit heures
de maquillage d'europe de trucs l'autre
aussi qui est avec elle une terrasse il
arrive en plateau à la fin de l'émission
je leur dis ouais on aurait dû la
chocolatées me dise non mais attention
si on l'avait chocolatées peut-être là
on aurait pris un procès parce que en
fait genre elle est égérie d'une marque
chez pas quoi les marques de luxe tout
ça j'ai dit on aurait dû la chocolatées
quand même mort a dit ça nous une zone
ils m'ont dit ça nous aurait coûté des
millions bon donc écouter a priori on
aura peut-être de là chocolatées mais
pour moi je suis sa liste et rod
l'invité la plus relou qu'on ait vue
dans l'émission questions action vérité
si l'an prochain tu devais partir ou sur
tf1 ou sur france 3 tu es ou house sur
tf1 et sur france 3 alors là là non je
prends une action je prends une action
je prends une action je suis désolé je
prends une action et chérie tu es en
france - j'ai pas envie de me plaindre
ouais boire un verre de fond tard et ça
c'est à dire soldats orange avec de
larissa il va vraiment jeu
j'y reste c'est qu'on se marre un petit
bordé parce que je suis pas bien en ce
moment j'ai des problèmes gastriques au
musculaire ah les cons à notre taille
jamais ça ne le fait jamais allée
d'autres questions pour le question pour
l'action vérité question ba ba ba ba
envisage une réconciliation avec tf1
comme tu l'avais annoncé en janvier 2020
vous savez ce que je vais faire je peux
appeler en direct le grand patron de tf1
a appris qu'en essayé de me réconcilier
avec lui est ce que vous le voulez oui
eh ben c'est parti on y va aller je
l'appelle depuis mais jamais mon
portable bien entendu parce qu'elle est
numéro les chérir
c'est parti allez on l'appelle on
l'appelle on va voir s'ils me répond
pour l'instant les mecs n'ont rien a
fait 1-1 ap un qui m'a répondu ah ça
sonne je veux dire qu'on voulait lui
faire un petit bisou c'est important
ça va hélas là franchement on est tous
amis là c'est bon quoi on n'est pas dans
ces guerres de chaîne on s'y réponds pas
je vous dirai quand même un petit truc
sur tf1 d'un message après 2004 une fois
votre message enregistré quand vous
pouvez raccrocher ou catégoriels pour le
médecin baracetti cyril hanouna
hattestad d'autre à [ __ ] que de me
répondre
tu vas me dire que tu es déborder là on
est confiné chez nous donc rappelle moi
mon haras et puis concevoir un petit peu
là ça y est là c'est fini la guerre là
haut on est tous ensemble à mon art je
t'embrasse mon chéri je te fais un gros
bisou bon bah voilà
mais il me répond pas bon alors je vous
racontais un petit truc sur tf1 quand
même je vous le dis sur tf1 ya un petit
bail qui se passe en ce moment vous avez
vu que vous avez canal canal +
gratuitement ce moment et tf1 ils ont
tellement mis la pression
ils ont mis la pression c'est ça ils ont
mis la pression à tout le monde sait que
ils valent absolument que canal+
s'arrête parce qu'ils sont dans une
guerre économique qui disent ouais comme
canal+ maintenant et en clair le soir il
faut savoir que hier soir canal+ ils ont
fait 1 17 million de téléspectateurs
donc ça a été énorme ils étaient devant
france 3 hier canal+ en clair donc
forcément ça commence à faire chier donc
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que tf1 a
mis une pression et à partir de la
semaine prochaine
vous aurez toujours la chaîne canal+
mais ils n'auraient pas toutes les
chaînes qui vont avec c'est à dire
canal+ série voilà canal+ chez papa
comédie voilà commis dit plus
13ème rue toutes les chaînes de canal
sais pas quoi là tout bouquet vous
l'aurez pas vous aurez que canal+
parce qu'ils ont mis une telle pression
que voilà ils nous ont fait enlever tout
ce dossier là tout ce truc là vous
comprenez au palais chéri voilà donc il
ya une grosse pression de tf1 et voilà
ils sont dans lara sera économique donc
forcément ils font chier les chéris je
voudrais vous dire hier vous le savez
c'est vrai qu'on vit une période
compliquée et on n'a pas besoin de
problèmes en plus pourtant c'est ce qui
est arrivé hier pendant cette émission
puisque j'ai eu un petit souci
un mini souci regardez j'espère que ça
va pas m'arriver aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui je suis seul regarde
panique chez cyril mais ils sont pris
par le temps n'est pas dans notre
culture comme en affaires mais que
cherche-t-il que se passe-t-il un
astéroïde s'approche de la terre non
bien pire
mais il faut trouver un écho voilà bah
ça c'était hier richir y est on a aussi
regardé parce que j'ai eu un petit
problème
et hier il y avait donc matthieu
delormeau et gilles verdez qui était
avec moi et j'ai un problème
physiologique de pression et regardez
moi la réaction de ces 2 tarbes a quand
même hein il va arriver dans un instant
l aga olivier habite fait on l'a pas
celui dans la base c'est un seul mec
travail et moi qu'est qui avoue lui a
voulu travailler quoi mitraille de
shelby et ils vivront là pas celui-là on
l'a sur un autre ton gauche est la
personnalité que tu ne voudra jamais
voir dans tpm p franchement la
personnalité que je n'aurais jamais voir
dans tpm p bon bah michel cymes rahim
soul quel invité rêve d'études avant
d'enter pmp fabrice luchini j'adore une
soirée dark avec michel boujenah ou
saurait d'arca avec margot robbie une
soirée dark avec michel boujenah je suis
fan absolu il est exceptionnel
tu préfères castaldi ou de leur goût là
je peux par exemple la plupart et
demande donc je suis obligé de prendre
une action à tokyo et d'action ah ouais
ouais ouais
à cela je peux pas finir l'émission en
caleçon un tee shirt je vais le faire
mais sera tout à l'heure mais ça va être
long à chaque retour pub faire à
retourner de perruques ce sera fait les
cherry à chaque retour pub je ferai un
retourné de perruques ne vous inquiétez
pas on va le voir on va le faire ça ça
dans un instant les chiffres il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de tweets voilà qui
arrive peux-tu quel invité regretter
d'avoir
le sort s'acharne hier vous m'avez en
images ce soir vous avez eu ma voix le
principal c'est que vous alliez bien
c'était valérie benaïm qui nous donne de
ses nouvelles
voilà il ya des gens ici qui me disent
tu peux tu nous faire visiter la maison
alors oui je vous faire visiter un petit
peu là bas la cuisine tout à l'heure
donc voilà comme ça deviendra avec moi
en cuisine vous allez voir comment ça se
passe les chéris c'est extrêmement sympa
vous allez voir ça allez c'est parti on
continue le action vérité les shihri on
a des questions qui arrive
ne vous inquiétez pas on est bien et
j'ai plein de vidéos à vous montrer dans
un instant tient à la question il ya une
question qui arrive qu'un je vais en
choisir une pop up bas quelle est
l'émission que tu regrettes d'avoir
animé l'émission que je regrette d'avoir
animé away a envoyé une émission j'ai
pas du tout qui fait c'est vrai c'était
c'était au cover the cover alors c'est
vrai que c'était dur mais c'était
tellement drôle de joie compte à chaque
fois l'histoire c'est qu'il ya une meuf
l'émission était tellement pourri c'est
qu'il ya une fan
voilà qui m'a vu après l'émission elle
m'a regardé comme ça la fille on dirait
que le monde s'était écroulé
et ça ça m'a sauvé ça c'était
exceptionnel c'était un des plus beaux
moments de ma vie
d'autres questions je vous rappelle
qu'ils peuvent ils peuvent arriver dans
un instant pourquoi camille combal nous
a pas répondu parce que l'ex boss en ce
moment mais il va nous rappeler
peut-être plus tard camille combal et
voilà c'est ce que vous vouliez ses
démons gage mon genre voilà on n'est pas
bien là on est bien là comme ça voilà on
est bien on est dans la folie là j'ai
remarqué les mecs qui ont les cheveux
longs font toujours un petit geste comme
as tu vois genre ils sont ils sont
faites au thomas à mais bon ça c'est
fait bon les chéris ya 18 mois avec qui
est là en fait ce talent qui va pouvoir
répondre à toutes vos questions
juste avant les chéris je vous le dis
j'ai ma fille ma psy s'allume ou jimmy
sa maman chérie
merci
et oui tu m'entends mohamed guy bon ben
schachter pas jimmy donc d'apparaître
ouvert son micro chez lui voilà va
regarder si le 10000 euros micro jimmy
est ouvert pour le moment les chéris je
voudrais appeler juste ma fille de
seconde
ma fille je crois qu'a fait une chanson
et mon fils ken back donc vous le savez
on est en direct et apparemment voilà
qu'ils sont sont actuellement
mais c'est le barca même ma fille me
répond pas quand c'est une canard c'est
quand même quoi est centrée à la loi
l'eau il paraît qu'il ya des chansons il
paraît qu'il ya des blagues pour moi ça
se passe où l'attend à travailler très
vite
bon bah alors un lit on écoute parce que
là on est devant des millions de
téléspectateurs le shérif matt était
parti va glisser ma chérie c'est dur car
c'est pas professionnel allechi rien je
vais [ __ ] tout ça ne vous dit ça va
être le début d'un matelas papa à
l'émission les vitraux du cac c'est bon
c'est bon
bravo et magnétiques prendre au bâti
merci matière
voila voila merci et est l'idole à peine
blague qu'elle approuverait pour passer
quoi touche à son corps waouh pas mal
fort voilà n'hésitez pas voilà c'est la
preview téléphone je vous aime mais
chérie je vous fais des groupes bisous
et bravo et bravo jean jacques goldman
peu ce vraiment peut se cacher sur les
paroles là on est bien je vous embrasse
les autres salles est lobé et
d'embrassades salut quoi on adore est
pour la vie le micro de jimmy moi mais
vous avez quitté la chanson est ce
qu'elle a dit ma fille elle a dit restez
chez vous
elle a dit allez on n'a pas le micro du
nîmois mètres mais j'ai des questions
les shérifs on m'avait posé plein de
questions on aura dit me remettre dans
un instant ne vous inquiétez pas cyril
quelle est ta technique pourri ce qu'il
est un mec qui plus de la bouche comment
lui dire sans le vexer alors ça c'est
extrêmement compliqué alors il faut voir
déjà si la personne c'est un problème
récurrent ou est-ce que si c'est un
problème
seulement voilà passagers c'est à dire
c'est une personne voilà qui a pu mais
de la bouche une fois comme ça parce que
elle a eu à l'abroger quelque chose qui
n'allait pas si c'est quelqu'un qui a un
problème récurrent à qui vous vous
toujours vous dire des secrets là c'est
un problème plus épineux moi j'aimerais
enfin qu par exemple faire un pote sans
déconner il avait un magasin de cuir
dans la bouche
ça veut dire il ouvrait la bouche mon
frère tu avais débat vous je t'avais des
trois quarts en cuir tu avais des blues
on se connaissait les magasins en
turquie quand vous passez devant frères
dès qu'il ouvrait la bouche c'était un
truc de ouf
alors je l'adoré ce mec et josé pas lui
dire et pourtant on est ensemble voilà
voilà à côté tout ça pour aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que l'on doit rester à
distance donc c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle mais une personne
il faut lui dire moi je pense que
franchement il faut lui dire avec les
mots avec les pinces et il faut dire
voilà écoute je t'adore tard toutes les
qualités des beaux gosses t sympathique
tu as tout pour toi mais tu as un petit
souci jeu peut-être peut-être que c'est
pas de ton fait peut-être que voilà
c'est les problèmes gastriques peut-être
que voilà tu as un petit problème
d'hygiène buccale donc voilà je pense
que c'est ça aussi qu'il faut faire et
je me demande si tu devrais pas faire
quelque chose voilà la personne au moins
vous vous lui direz et je peux vous dire
que ça va lui servir pour les autres
voilà moi c'est ce que je ferai c'est
léo qui map qui m'a demandé ça il ya
s'initier à london qui me dit cyril veux
tu m'épouser des gens à passer le
coronavirus me cynthia et après on verra
pas ce que tu es donc voilà c'est pas du
tout à l'ordre du jour cyril as tu déjà
eu un rapport avec un mec si oui à tuer
mais alors alexandre robert je respecte
bien sûr toutes les personnes voilà et
vous faites ce que vous voulez et si
bien voilà moi j'aime la liberté la
liberté dans tous les sens du terme mais
non moi voilà l'enjeu est là je n'ai
jamais essayé
voilà je vois là pour je n'ai jamais
essayé je vois là je ne suis pas
voilà pour l'instant je ne suis pas
ouvert voilà mais pour l'instant je n'ai
jamais essayé donc je peux pas te dire
si j'ai aimé ou pas as tu trouvé là l'on
a dû trouver d'autres talents de salon
avec celle avec les cercles merci je ne
comprends pas mais c'est pas baba dit
toujours la vérité si oui elle par
double en brouille avec tf1 tient ses
amis qui me disent ah bah je voulais
dire l'andouille avec tf1 je vais vous
dire d'où elle pas et ben en fait les
anciens patrons de ces mythes son parti
à tf1
et quand ils sont partis à tf1 ils ont
essayé de nous piquer tous les mecs qui
travaillait chez moi et puis ils ont
essayé de faire une émission qui était à
peu près pareil que touche pas à mon
poste avec des gens qui travaillaient
chez moi ils ont essayé de faire sept à
huit avec arthur donc voilà aujourd'hui
on en est pas dans les guéguerres
franchement on s'en fout on voit
aujourd'hui qu'il ya beaucoup plus grave
que la télé il ya beaucoup plus grave
que tout ça mais voilà je voulais juste
te répondre donc c'était ça dès qu'ils
sont partis ils ont appelé tous les gars
qui étaient avec moi pour essayer de
travailler avec eux ce soit des gens de
la technique des moteurs des auteurs et
pour faire 7 à 8 avec arthur et après
ils ont régulièrement essayé de
m'appliquer des gens et d'essayer de me
mettre des bâtons dans les roues
voilà parce que c'est vrai qu'il n'était
plus avec nous
dans le groupe canal+ mais il était
parti dans le groupe tf1 dont tu me
rappelles il avait même un dossier
geôliers qui s'appelait killer tpm pays
c'est à dire comment tu es touche pas à
mon poste voilà bon ils n'ont pas réussi
mais aujourd'hui je vais vous dire on
s'en fout on espère qu'on va se
réconcilier avec eux vous l'avez vu j'ai
même appelé art africain le patron voilà
où on est on est plus là dedans
franchement n'est plus là dedans on est
dans la réconciliation là il faut qu'on
soit tous main dans la main et qu'on
essaie d'avancer tous main dans la main
pour voilà pour pour essayer de
combattre ce [ __ ] de virus et
franchement on en a rien à [ __ ] des
embrouilles des chaînes et des
embrouilles économique des chaînes on
s'en tape total tu préfère donner un
prime à isabelle morini-bosc ou faire un
bisou sur les pieds de gilles verdez non
c'est prime à isabelle direct ya même
pas à chier puis la belle sera pas mal
en plus quelle est la première chose que
tu as pensé quand tu rencontré matthieu
delormeau pour la première fois alors
quand j'ai rencontré pour la première
fois déjà j'étais très en retard et je
me suis dit pareil il est
il est plus beau en vrai qu'à la télé il
est pas mal hein il a une belle poule
ils rimbaud porter tête ya un pop corn
oil où il est bon il est beau c'est une
star ac une star il est beau il est
magnifique
voilà après après le seul problème qui
la leur on sait tous c'est qu'il faut
qu'il arrête de se prendre pour une star
c'est vrai que c'est une star mais il
faut qu'il arrête de se prendre pour une
star
voilà il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
redescendent un peu mais je vais vous
dire comme je dis à chaque fois je vous
jure c'est ce que je dis à chaque fois
que mes équipes jeudi mine de rien les
talons ça se gère et matthieu delormeau
qu'on le veuille ou non c'est un talent
exceptionnel franchement c'est un talent
comme on en voit très très peu et
forcément qui s' il est un peu plus
chiant que les autres enfin il est un
peu plus diva que les autres mais il a
un talent exceptionnel et il a un coeur
énorme
voilà mais c'est vrai que voilà à bâle
et allons forcément c'est plus difficile
à gérer que des gens qui sont en bas là
qui sont un petit peu dans mon lui voilà
il arrive un petit pet au casque c'est
pour ça qu'on lève et il est fabuleux